[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute gibt es wieder was
österreichisches wir sind noch alles ein
bisschen in österreich fieber und ich
mache heute semmelknödel die haben wir
dort auch gegessen aber ich muss auch
sagen ich kenne die schon von meinen
bayerischen verwandten aus landau an der
isar und die haben wir auch immer gerne
gemacht und es war über ganz witzig weil
ich dort beim bäcker immer wenn ich
brötchen holen sollte dann brötchen
bestellt habe aber die wussten nicht was
ich will halt dort heißt semmeln
deswegen semmelknödel die semmelknödel
das ist echt ein richtig tolles basic
rezept weil ihr das immer zu bereiten
könnt wenn ihr altes brot oder alte
brötchen da habt und ihr könnt ihr auch
ganz gut einfrieren und es passt
irgendwie auch zu allem in österreich
haben was zu gulasch gegessen heute
werde ich aber so blitzen machen also
das ganze heute vegetarisch halten für
die semmelknödel verwende ich fünf
brötchen vom vortag also die dürfen
ruhig als 125 milliliter milch drei
eiern eine zwiebel petersilie 60 gramm
butter salz und pfeffer ich nehme jetzt
zuerst die zwiebel dem bereits geschält
und ich schneide ich jetzt in feine
würfel und kann ihn da zwischenzeit
schon mal die butter in einer pfanne
erhitzen zwiebel werden jetzt nämlich
angeordnet so haben wir dann richtig
tollen geschmack
[Musik]
1 zwiebel hier bei mittlerer stufe etwa
drei bis vier minuten anbraten und in
der zwischenzeit kann ich einfach schon
mal das brot in feine würfel schneiden
[Musik]
ihr könnt hier zum beispiel auch andere
brötchen nehmen also es müssen nicht nur
weiße brötchen oder weißes brot sein
ihr könnt auch laugenbrezel nehmen oder
auch roggen dinkel brötchen egal das was
ihr gerade da hab ich werde jetzt auch
einfach zwei brötchen austauschen ohne
um diese lauge plätze dazu geben es gibt
dann noch mal einen kräftigeren
geschmack
[Musik]
das gebe ich die an gebratenen zwiebeln
hier mit rein dann spiele ich einfach
mit der milch fahne aus
[Musik]
denn hier auf die eier dazu die
petersilie die habe ich bereits fein
gehackt damit diese salz und pfeffer
abschmecken
es ist immer so extrem viel aus aber
sind nicht so viel was hier raus kommt
jetzt alles schön durchführen
und wenn ich die semmelknödel später
dampft dann braucht ihr jetzt keinen
mehr für die bindung weil sie da nicht
freischwimmen sondern festsitzen
aber ich werde sie gleich in salzwasser
garen und da ist es daneben noch gut
wenn ihr noch mehr dazu gibt einfach für
die bindung
[Musik]
wenn jetzt merkt dass die macher noch zu
trocken ist können wir noch ein schluck
milch dazugeben
da kommt einfach auch ein bisschen immer
darauf an wie groß die eier sind
[Musik]
teller drauf zum abdecken und kann jetzt
die maße für 30 minuten ruhen lassen so
dass es schön durchziehen
die knödel masse dürfte jetzt gut
durchziehen davor mich gleich mit
feuchten händen die semmelknödel daraus
kann jetzt aber auch schon mal das bild
rako zubereiten ich mache jetzt
pilzragout dazu schön vegetarisch und es
ist auch wirklich super lecker und vor
allem was wir den herbst für die
fertigen rahmsauce verwende ich 800
gramm pilze da habe ich jetzt peter
linge weiße und braune champignons 60
gramm butter eine zwiebel oder 2
schalotten 80 milliliter sahne 200 gramm
saure sahne ein bisschen petersilie
zitronensaft mehl salz pfeffer und
muskat charlotten werden jetzt zuerst
einmal geschält
kann ich die charlotte in feine würfel
schneiden und zeitgleich auch schon mal
wasser aufsetzen für die senderkette
[Musik]
und die großen champignons die habe ich
bereits geputzt die werden nicht
gewaschen sondern einfach nur so ein
bisschen abgerieben und die kann ich
jetzt einfach vierter
[Musik]
zum semmelknödel form und einfach die
hände ein bisschen anfeuchten und auch
gerne das schneidet oder trop ist gleich
drauf legt oder den teller
aber das sparen jetzt wissen geschieht
dann mit der hand funktionieren und
schöne knödel formen
sobald die knödel geformt sind kann ich
jetzt schon mal die butter erhitzen in
der pfanne und die zwiebeln darin
anbraten
[Musik]
jetzt stelle ich die semmelknödel hier
zur seite das wasser kann ich jetzt ein
bisschen runter stellen und hier auf
jeden fall noch salz dazugeben gilt
jetzt ganz langsam ins wasser gleiten
lassen und dann nicht mehr kochen
sondern erst sieben und dann brauchen
sie je nach größe zu etwa zehn bis zwölf
minuten
nämlich die pilze die kommen jetzt zur
angebratenes bibel dazu und dürfen dann
so etwa fünf minuten angebraten werden
in kathy fear verlinkt finde ich hier in
dem rezept wirklich sehr genial
ich habe mal den büchern nach
pfifferlingen guckt und in
österreichischen rezepten und dann
herausgefunden
die heißen dort zu verlängern
wahrscheinlich weil sie so schwammig
schmecken
hier kann ich jetzt schon mal das mädel
mit dem sauerrahm verrühren dann ist sie
schon mal bereit für die soße
das kann ich hier die sahne dazugeben
löschen
wer möchte kann auch weißwein zum
beispiel zufügen oder gemüsebrühe
aber ich finde der geschmack der pilze
reicht auf jeden fall schon aus den
sauerrahm mit dem meer
das habe ich es einfach vorher verrührt
damit das mehl keine klümpchen bildet
aber ich brauche natürlich für die
bindung der soße uns auch gern die hitze
ein bisschen runter nehmen
dann kommt ein bisschen vertonen saft
dazu zum abschmecken
diese muss christian salz und pfeffer
und damit sie so schon fertig und die
semmelknödel zeitgleich
[Musik]
schon ist das essen fertig komm her dass
der weg würde
je nachdem wie groß der sommer ist
können auch preis ein bisschen von der
pilze
schade dass morata da ist mal erlebt
pfifferlinge und champignons und er
sagte noch immer da brauche absolut kein
fleisch dazu bisschen pfeffer und
gehackte petersilie das rezept könnt ihr
nachlesen ob sallys blog.de ich hoffe es
gefällt euch probiert auf jeden fall mal
aus und wenn ihr möchtet dass sich
weitere semmelknödel videos machen
dann schreibt in die kommentare denn es
gibt noch die gefüllte variante die
spinnenart variante also da gibt es ganz
viele variationen und es gibt auch süße
knödel und jetzt lassen wir es uns mit
meinem team schmecken also wissen von
dem von der semmelknödel dann bisschen
soße prüften und es uns einen guten
appetit und euch viel spaß beim
nachmachen zu probieren
[Musik]
in österreich
vorabend
[Musik]
neu bei box
kuchen backen kuchen ohne zucker also
ohne industriezucker sally zaubert
rasses für kleine naschkatzen
ich habe eine ganz andere teig art
erfunden aus datteln so gesund so lecker
und es wird ein regenbogen kuchen und
ich hoffe dass er gut ankommen aber auch
süß genug für diese schüler
[Musik]
sonntag 16 uhr bei vox